pour o
non
depuis plus d'un an la palette jupiter
nous dévoile son nouveau visage grâce à
la mission juno cette semaine comme tous
les deux mois environ
la sonde américaine effectue un vol en
rase motte au dessus de cet immense
planète gazeuse
cet été elle a capté les premiers gros
plan de la célèbre tache rouge une
tempête grande comme la terre
[Musique]
avec chaque passage de juno la surface
de jupiter se révèle plus riche plus
complexe que prévu
mais la grande surprise se trouve au
pôle un bleu profond constaté des
dizaines de cyclones que juneau a été la
première à voir
car son orbite est unique elle survole
jupiter du nord au sud en frôlant
l'équateur
son champ de vision embrasse d'abord la
planète entière observe les nombreuses
bandes de nuages qui l'encerclent avant
découvrir notre pôle le tout en deux
heures à peine
mais la véritable mission de juno c'est
de regarder sous la surface de jupiter
d'étudier sa structure sa dynamique à
l'inter
la sonde porte d'ailleurs le nom d'une
déesse capable de voir à travers les
nuages
elle est équipée d'une série
d'instruments qui révèle l'intérieur de
la planète
on savait déjà que jupiter et est avant
tout faite d'hydrogène à la surface il
est sous forme gazeuse
mais avec la pression l'hydrogène
devient d'abord dit qui depuis tellement
dense qu'il se comporte comme un métal
au centre il y avait deux hypothèses un
petit noyau de roche ou de glace ou au
que noyau pour résoudre l'énigme
la sonde juno a étudié les changements
dans l'attraction que la planète exerce
sur elle cette variation de trajectoire
lui permet de déduire ce qui se trouve
en dessous
et d'après les premiers résultats tout
le monde avait tort
il y aurait en fait un noyau plutôt
volumineux mais à moitié fondue les
chercheurs parlent de noyaux flou du
noyau diffus à défaut d'une meilleure
description
autre mission de juno c'est d'étudier le
sens magnétiques de jupiter qui est
beaucoup plus puissante prévu sa source
est à l'intérieur de la planète environ
au quart de la profondeur la pression il
devient si forte que les molécules
d'hydrogène se disloque les électro
circulent alors librement au milieu des
protons et ce flot de particules
chargées créé le champ magnétique pour
les chercheurs jupiter est un immense
laboratoire de physique ou la matière
est soumise à des conditions extrêmes au
point où on découvre des phénomènes dont
on ne soupçonnait même pas l'existence
par exemple un nouveau type de rohr
boréale comme sur terre les peaux de
jupiter s'illumine quand ils sont
bombardés par des particules émises par
le soleil mais pour les horreurs les
plus fortes ici en rouge ni particules
proviennent de l'intérieur de la planète
et wrap l'atmosphère par en dessous
un mécanisme qu'on s'explique encore mal
pour étudier de tels phénomènes
il a fallu relever certains défis de
conception même pour une sonde spatiale
c'est à l'environnement hostile
pour protéger l'électronique des
radiations les ingénieurs ont conçu une
voûte de titane de 200 kg cette paroisse
ne bloque pas complètement les
radiations mais elles ont réduit
l'intensité
autre innovation la sonde fonctionne
entièrement à l'énergie solaire
c'est une première autour de jupiter où
le soleil est 25 fois moins puissant que
sur terre mais ses efforts en valais
coup la sonde juno a ébranlé tout ce
qu'on pensait savoir sur jupiter
elle force les spécialistes à revoir
leurs idées sur les canettes géantes
gazeuses et elle ravive l'intérêt pour
celles qui n'ont jamais été étudié en
profondeur
uranus et neptune sous leurs dehors
plutôt fade
yat-il bel et bien des pluies diamant
géants comme le veut une des hypothèses
actuelles
[Musique]